you said twelve to twenty so
eight or nine years
seven seasons 151 episodes um
those years so so and that was like
network television when network
television was still like yeah yeah you
know it was pre
i mean i would say pre-internet but
barely like you know youtube yeah it was
there was no youtube there was no social
media
there was it was uh it was network tv or
basic cable yeah and that was it it was
it was crazy though because like you
know obviously as a as an actor or
anything that you do right you
you know i got the i remember
auditioning and i didn't want to go to
the audition because i was supposed to
film a pizza hut commercial that day and
i was like mom we cannot be late to the
pizza commercial she said we'll go early
we'll go early so she
we went in the casting director wasn't
even there she walked over like can we
just be seen real fast i went in i was
like
like i don't even care just say the
words i gotta go pizza hut you know what
i mean this is my big break and um
and they call and they're like you're
malcolm so you get the pilot you film
the pilot you know and you think there's
what of 200 pilots a year
right six or seven get picked up and
then what they get picked up and only
two of those make it past episodes
and so i remember every step of the way
just being like
whoa this is happening and the first
time i was
we lived in new jersey and i uh i
auditioned for stuff in new york city we
lived like 10 miles from new york city
and we took the subway and there was
malcolm middle posters all over the
subway
and someone like came up to me and was
like oh you're going to be on that show
that's you and i was like that was the
coolest thing in the history of life wow
but then
you still don't think anyone's going to
watch it like you don't know right i
don't feel like like i feel like now
people have an idea if something's going
to be super successful well do you know
what channel was going to be on it was
on fox we knew it was going to be
everybody's going to watch that [ __ ]
well i don't i don't know you know and
and the first episode aired and 23
million people tuned in oh [ __ ] and then
they re-aired it on wednesday and 28
million people tuned in wow
and then we knew we were like oh wow
this is
this actually is going to be pretty cool
how many people were watching jackass
like season one i mean dude they would
be like the most was like four million
on mtv well because it was cable too
like this was never like i didn't have
cable but like i would watch them in the
middle you know yes network tv was a
much bigger deal than basic cable yeah
so your mom took you to auditions and
stuff was your mom like managing your
career and stuff i i
yeah i don't know if she ever fully
took on that
label or that role but like it was you
know i when i was a kid i'd go from
football practice to a baseball game to
you know auditions to tap and jazz
whatever it was you know to me so she
just kind of made sure i got where i
needed to go and then it took over my
life you know what i mean like and it
took over her life too you know what i
mean so i'm super grateful
for her to think now of like
wow
i could have had a parent that was like
no we're not going you know what i mean
right
exhausting to do all that stuff yeah and
uh so
yeah and so you had earned i'm guessing
a whopping amount of money but by the
time you turned 18.
and uh
so does that mean that um
like
like aaron carter was telling us that
they just like established some law that
parents have to like save
like 15 percent
yeah the coogan law so i automatically
like a check from fox doesn't go to me
whatever the percentage is i forget what
it is
goes to a trust like it goes into like
an account that you can't touch until 18
because there's been supposedly in the
past so many kid actors that they work
and the parents spend all the money
right you know and so at least they
would have that maybe it's 15 or 20
percent it's unbelievable they they they
passed a lot to say that parents can
only blow 85
yeah
but were your parents pretty like good
with the money and stuff and like i mean
we hired you know business managers like
that you know right away um
uh
yes
i'm very fortunate in that sense like my
mom never wanted to spend any money like
you know we were always very
i call the
frugal you know what i mean like outside
of the cars outside of the car well that
was like i said it was my one right you
know thing where i go oh maybe i
shouldn't have done that you know what i
mean but uh
uh but no pretty i mean you could have
done a lot worse though because i also
read maybe this isn't true because i
read a lot but like uh you never really
got into drugs or drinking or anything
like that i've never
drank i've never done anything uh at all
so you could have blown a lot there and
i didn't like crazy 16 years old going
to the playboy mansion every night so
okay
so that's what i was going to say like
so life did get kind of crazy like you
were like a kid celebrity you weren't
just like i go to work then i go home
and i'm just a normal kid you were like
i'm a celebrity i i didn't
i never enjoyed going out you know what
i mean i think that's part of it like i
went out like i'd go out every once in a
while and i just would get home at 2 00
2 30 in the morning and be like why that
was so stupid you know what i mean and
that so i it wasn't my thing um but no
but i definitely i have stories for sure
you know what i mean yeah crazy life
experiences that yeah i mean what was
the playboy mansion like for a 15 year
old
heaven
so did you
like get invested in like real estate
and stuff like i just think [ __ ] man if
if i had like
been better with investments if i'd
gotten like real estate like early on or
like what i would like
i did i i
unknowingly made choices not unknowingly
like just thought it was like on a whim
kind of things that worked out really
well you know what i mean i was never
the type of person where i was like oh i
got to think strategically it was more
like oh this seems cool and like i'd buy
a house or like you know
i had a bunch of houses at one time and
the market went crazy so i made a ton of
money on them you know what i mean but
it was never like uh you know people i
own some parking lots in downtown l.a
wow
you know you know downtown l.a from i
don't know 2002 there was really nothing
there and now it became like a pretty
trendy there's so much down there so i
did really well there so stuff like that
still have them no i sold them in 2006.
i wish i had them now because then
they'd be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars was like
an apartment building built there yeah
yeah yeah things was a pretty good time
to get out
yes well yes in the sense that right
before the big
housing price that we were talking about
if you still had it now now like now
it's right things are playing like the
monthly income from that is [ __ ]
crazy right you know you have like one
or two employees who take money all day
from cars you know what i mean right
there's no
what streets were your parking lots we
were all around staples center um all
around so you got a lot yeah jesus dude
way to go how do you think to get in the
parking lots who tells you that
i just i i'm a weird person in the sense
that like when i was a kid i wanted to
be like a garbage man or want to be a
trained conductor and i always like i
want to own storage facilities the
stupid like that's just where my brain
goes and that was one of those where i
was like
why don't we buy this because
even if you're only charge i would go
like even if you're only charging five
dollars a car which people down here are
charging twenty dollars to park you know
what i mean we could be the cheap block
you know what i mean yeah and
you're going to have people all day
coming through
and
i don't know i just excited
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
this big badass tour bus is coming to
your town with my bucket list tour what
is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude